-Hey, everybody.
I'm fighting a cold.
So fair warning, tonight's
pacing will be lethargic.
I was told in
no uncertain terms
that you shouldn't drink
your own urine
if you're in the desert, it will
only dehydrate you faster.
Worst comes to worst,
they recommend
a half a glass of Coors Light.
[ Laughter ]
We made a joke that
the GOP governs like a Roomba.
If it bumps into something
it doesn't understand,
it goes the opposite direction.
Someone commented
that Roombas don't turn back
in the opposite direction
when they hit something.
That would just result in one
line being cleared in a room.
No one wants that.
They bounce around it, trying
to get a sense of the object.
I don't bring it up
because of that.
I bring it up because
the very next comment,
referring to the one
I just read to you was,
"Oh, look at Richie Rich
over here with his Roomba."
[ Laughter ]
That's a sort of
jackal-on-jackal action
that gets me up in the morning.
I showed you
some great M&Ms last week
that were worth $1,000,000 each,
thanks to M&Ms 1997 Find
the Imposter M&M Campaign.
Excuse me,
a few of you said the M&Ms
I showed didn't look gray,
they looked silver, and well,
the folks at the Mars Candy
Corporation agreed with you.
That was an awkward meeting,
to say the least.
And a real reminder for me
not to say,
"Do you know who I am?"
because in that case, they did
and they didn't care.
Also, they were very --
they were very rude.
It was just a bunch --
You know,
Mars Candy Corporation.
They're top of the mountain
and they know it.
You should see
their boardroom --
all glass, gorgeous, beautiful
suits, Italian tailors.
And they're just sitting around,
and then they start
giving me the high hat.
Here I am, just an honest guy
trying to get
a million bucks each for
my gray M&Ms.
And they're saying, "Those
aren't gray, they're silver.
And also, why is there silver
Sharpie all over your hands?"
And I'm like, "Um, 'cause I
sign headshots all day long."
And they say,
"Who asks you to sign headshots
all day long?"
And I say, "Anybody who asks."
And they say,
"Where do they ask you?"
And I'm like, "Outside 30 Rock,
every day I walk out."
And one of them said,
"Hey, I'll make you a deal.
We'll walk there
with you right now,
and if someone asks you
to sign a headshot,
we'll give you
the million dollars."
And I was like,
"I don't want it like that."
[ Laughter ]
We always say Trump talks like
he's holding
a invisible accordion.
A gentleman wrote and said
it would be more accurate
to say an invisible concertina,
because accordions have keys
and a concertina
does not have keys.
The guy who told me that
was weird...
...Al Yankovic.
I said the word comptroller.
It's pronounced "controller."
And it's true.
Double checked it. Googled it.
On my computer.
Con-puter?
[ Laughter ]
Biden wasn't at a podium.
He was at a lectern.
Lectern is easy to remember,
because it's where you stand
to lecture, and lecture
is easy to remember
because it's what
jackals do to get off.
You don't pay for continental
breakfast at a Motel Six.
Should have said Motel Five.
Bass joke.
We called Herschel Walker
a vampire enthusiast.
That's incorrect. He's
a former vampire enthusiast.
Because he was watching
the movie "Fright Night."
That's the clip. The whole clip
that made him famous.
He discovered watching
a horror movie
that he stumbled upon one night.
He used to think
vampires are cool,
but then he discovered that
werewolves can kill vampires.
Shoemaker, remember
what can kill a werewolf?
-Half a glass of Coors Light.
-♪ The right beer now ♪
[ Laughter ]
We received --
I received to the P.O. box,
two wedding invitations.
Asking, inviting not just me,
but also Wally
to attend their weddings.
So to Brianna and Matthew,
Steph and Alex,
we wish you the best
in your matrimonial endeavor.
I unfortunately cannot make it,
and I will not be
sharing the details
of your wedding with Wally.
I have been at weddings
with Wally,
and this has happened
more than once.
I was hopeful we'd received
the last of our
Mack Tonight fan art
because none had arrived
last week.
But false alarm.
Guess it was just cloudy.
That's not a nice way
to use your time.
I certainly don't care
for the lack of bravery
I'm showing in the knife's
reflective edge.
I'm going to show you this one
in part because
it's a photo of me
on a red carpet,
but they've replaced me,
Shoemaker.
So it's my beautiful wife,
Alexi, with this gentleman.
And I don't know if you can
tell that
in the reflective glasses
he's wearing,
that's me crying,
so I'm seeing it.
Is that the worst part
of the photo?
No, because this was an event
where my beautiful wife, Alexi,
was with child, and Jodie,
the artist in question,
wanted to let me know
whose child it was.
[ Laughter ]
Not cool, Jodie.
Relax. I don't know.
Oh, okay.
So this is cool, remember
I was trying to...
I got a Faberge egg, guys,
sent to me.
Pretty cool, right?
Here at "Late Night,"
every night I deliver
a monologue made up of jokes
written by
a diverse team of writers.
As a result, a lot of jokes
come across my desk
that are all about animals.
It's time for "Animal Flubs."
-♪ Animal Flubs, Animal Flubs ♪
♪ It's time to take a look
at some Animal Flubs ♪
♪ From the birds to the bees
to the baby bear cubs ♪
♪ It's time for Animal Flubs ♪
-♪ And I know you don't
need to say "baby" ♪
♪ Before you say "bear cub" ♪
♪ Because in that case,
"cub" means baby ♪
♪ But when you're
writing a song ♪
♪ On a Thursday afternoon ♪
♪ When you really should be
working on A Closer Look ♪
♪ Sometimes your guy
and I cut a few corners ♪
♪ In order to make
the rhyme scheme work ♪
-♪ Animal Flubs, Animal Flubs ♪
♪ I hope you're all ready
for some Animal Flubs ♪
♪ Call all your pals,
buddies, and buds ♪
♪ It's time for Animal Flubs ♪
-♪ And I hope you enjoy
the new voices ♪
♪ We added to this song ♪
♪ Because a bunch of you
were unhappy ♪
♪ So if you're sitting there
now upset at the fact ♪
♪ That we added a verse
to an overlong song ♪
♪ Then may we recommend
that you take it up with ♪
♪ The [bleep] who couldn't just
enjoy a nice thing ♪
-Enjoy a nice thing.
-♪ Animal Flubs, Animal Flubs ♪
♪ I hope you're all ready
for some Animal Flubs ♪
-♪ Pencil us in for
Best Emmy Song snub ♪
-♪ It's time for Animal Flubs ♪
-♪ F ♪
-♪ L ♪
-♪ U ♪
-♪ B ♪
-♪ S ♪
-♪ Are the letters ♪
♪ Used ♪
♪ To spell "flubs" ♪
♪ Animal Flubs ♪
Sorry.
I thought I had more time.
[ Laughter ]
It's e-"mew," not e-"mu."
It's quokka, not a "quo"-kka.
A koala baby isn't a cub,
it's a joey,
because a koala
isn't a bear, it's a marsupial.
I said we showed a dairy cow
instead of a beef cow
when we were talking about
the price of beef.
And someone wrote
that was okay, adding,
"What do people think happens
to dairy cows
once the milk production
falls too low?"
More importantly, what do
the dairy cows think happens?
"Well,
that's the end of my milk.
Now I retire to Paris."
[ Laughter ]
"That's right, Betsy.
That's right.
I just need you
to stop by the shed,
sign some papers."
[ Laughter ]
Oh, we said
the Son of Sam's dog
told him
to go on a killing spree.
It was his neighbor's dog.
The Son of Sam's dog
was the one who famously said,
"Don't listen to him."
He later recanted that the dog
told him to do it in prison,
which of course
means the dog got to him.
Someone said in response
to "Animal Flubs,"
"'Corrections' jumped the shark
when they started doing
pre-planned bits."
You're making "pre"
do a lot of work there.
Someone said based
on the opening package
of "Animal Flubs,"
"You have no idea how animals'
jaws or beaks work."
Well, pal, you've got no idea
how a graphic department works.
Last week, to get this
done on time,
when the show was over,
we had to put
Tara Donnelly on oxygen.
Okay?
What do you think I was going
to do at the end of the show?
Head on down
to the graphics room
with a big old book
of animal anatomy,
giving her a hard time?
"Tara, take your mask off.
I don't need her to breathe.
I need her to listen."
You can still go to jail
if you kill a bald eagle.
Sorry if I got your hopes up.
This has been "Animal Flubs."
-[ Shriek ]
-Seven days.